hi I'm Ria today I have a friend
challenging me to take a popular food
and make it fancy today's guest is
it's me Elise I am so excited for you to
see what I brought today
amazing
all right let's see what we are making
fancy today
Panda Express it's this orange chicken
I love orange chicken orange chicken is
like a staple and I think it would be an
interesting challenge for you too you
know make it fancy well you know just a
refresher let's try cheers
crunchy Saucy candy well you know
actually I have an additional Challenge
on top of what I've already given you I
want you to make this Panda Express
orange chicken into like a breakfast
hangover cure breakfast hangover cure
that's my challenge for you challenge
accepted all right I'm excited to make
it fancy all right here's what I got
asparagus still chives lemons grapefruit
shallots ground chicken arugura milk
butter and Panda Express orange sauce by
the way you can buy this much at
shop.buzzfeed.com from the pantry I got
olive oil canola oil rice vinegar white
vinegar Dijon mustard maple syrup honey
semolina flour Panko bread crumbs
instant yeast red pepper flakes brown
sugar ground allspice cayenne pepper and
smoked paprika alright let's get started
make it fancy so first step I have books
full of Panda Express orange chicken I'm
gonna do a little surgery looks so good
I want to separate chicken from the
breading something about this orange
chicken I crave once in a while so I
separated all chicken and breading and
I'm going to chop the chicken super fine
and I'm super excited what I'm going to
do with this later looks good so I'm
going to save this for later and I'm
going to spread this in
two potions I think orange chickens
tastes so good because it hits all the
flavor salt for acid and sweetness right
looks good and I'm going to put this in
a dehydrator until it becomes crispy
while it's dehydrating let's get fancy
[Music]
[Applause]
the seeds came out from the dehydrator
and it's so crispy I'm gonna try small
piece
like a meat candy sorry you guys cannot
taste it I'm going to put this in a
spice grinder and make it into coarse
powder all right now I have orange
chicken flavored powder I can't wait for
you to see how I'm going to use this
magical powder all right so since
Ellie's challenged me to make breakfast
I've decided to do some baking what's
better than fresh baked goods in the
morning I have half cup of water and
warm milk half cup and sugar risk a
little bit so sugar dissolve I'm going
to bloom East when you are using rapid
yeast you want to activate so you want
to use warm water or milk it's important
so you are making sure the yeast is not
bad I'm going to say aside about 5-10
minutes until it's for me right I have
all-purpose flour and I have powdered
chicken breading and adding salt I'm
gonna combine mix dry ingredients well
with whisk I have checked this is a
bloomed yeast and I'm going to add
I'm going to add X
melted butter whisk and I'm going to add
dry ingredients and wet mixture slowly
and I'm going to mix it with dough hook
until the dough is very elastic sprinkle
you want to knead the dough until
elastic you need dough to create gluten
so this dough supposed to be sticky like
this so I think it's ready and I'm going
to put in a glisced ball and we are
going to proof this dough until doubled
so I have proof the doll it is double in
size I'm gonna dust on my Surface that's
my rolling pin too so it produced gas I
kind of want to be gentle on it so I
don't want to refraine oh look at this I
want to roll this about an inch I'm
going to cut this one down and when you
are cutting and rolling make sure to
dust your utensils like that's your
rolling pin and that's your ring mold
look at my baby I have she pan with
semolina flour on it so it doesn't stick
and gives a nice kind of texture too my
orange chicken butter bread dough is
ready and let's cook them off I have
semolina flour and I'm going to sprinkle
on a pan and we are not using any
cooking oil so I'm going to cook on the
semolina flour about five minutes until
the bottom is golden brown one of the
indicator since we are using semolina
you can see semolina is getting brown
maybe it's ready let's see slippery oh
nice and I'm going to cook the other
side about five more minutes and I'm
going to cook off rest of the English
muffins so those look great and we are
going to finish this in oven at 350
about five minutes but most important
part is inner temperature it's 180
degrees so this is new element of my
dish and I brought back chopped chicken
right here ground chicken and chopped
chicken and I have maple syrup thyme
pepper our smoked paprika brown sugar
ground allspice salt and black pepper
I'm going to mix this the best kitchen
tool by hand and I'm going to divide
this into six even sides make sure
everything is kind of even cool I took
out sausage from the Fritter and it's
chilled the reason we chill this in the
freezer so it doesn't stick on the
bottom and I'm going to add oil
and put the ring mold so we can have
nice round shape and take out this
chilled sausage ball cook until browned
and or cooked through I have four more
to go and I'm gonna finish this and we
are moving on to next step so I have hex
and I'm going to separate I think this
is just a practice just go back and
forth and gently remove white so I have
a milk and orange sauce lemon juice salt
and cayenne pepper when you make
hollandaise sauce you usually use double
boiler but this is a tasty hack you can
use blender and I'm going to start the
Brenda and heat it up about 20 seconds
and then slowly add melted wombat you
want to blend egg yolk first to heat it
up so egg yolk and butter temperature
it's the same so the sauce won't be
separated this was so much faster and
easier using blender than a double
boiler my Hollandaise sauce looks
delicious and we are moving on to next
step I want to add some freshness into
my dish so I'm going to make a little
salad I have rice vinegar lemon juice so
I'm adding orange sauce because Elise
loved orange chicken honey
Chili Pepper flake and salt is to taste
did your mustard and olive oil I'm gonna
use imagine blender so it is easy and
faster to emulsify I'm gonna add minced
shallots and lemon zest I think it's
very vibrant fresh and there is a hint
of orange sauce okay salad is ready
let's move on we have boiling hot water
and I'm going to salt and white vinegar
the reason I put vinegar is hold the
shape better and I'm going to crack egg
and I'm going to create Vortex and I'm
going to drop egg look at this like
dancing being very careful not to break
the yolk the visual cue is inside it's
still jiggly and egg white is kind of
coated around it and another important
thing is you don't want to boil water
you want to make it simmer it's like
outside is completely cooked but inside
you can kind of see runny yolk so I made
poached egg but this is not it I'm going
to freeze this and Elevate this I have
dehydrated and ground orange chicken
breading I'm going to mix with panko
first I'm gonna coat this is not frozen
it's chilled still delicate so be gentle
hey gosh it's my hack when you are
breading something use one hand for egg
wash so the other hand is not dirty
right so I have hot oil here and I'm
going to fry them just wanted to make
outside crispy not fully cooked inside
one thing I think I'm surprised is here
in United States people eat greasy food
as a hangover cure when I get hungover I
usually want to eat something like light
rice porridge or Congee or miso soup
even so I feel like each country has a
different hangover cure right I think
it's good to go let's recap I have
dehydrated ground orange chicken
breading English Muffin breakfast
sausage with chopped orange chicken the
horrende sauce with the orange sauce
dressing with the orange sauce
dehydrated ground orange chicken
coated poached egg and I have blanched
asparagus and a chive and Dill recently
I learned you don't want to cut English
muffin with knife you want to use Fork
English muffin had nice and hot so it
doesn't destroy the holes just gently
break perfect let's assemble I'm gonna
put some salad aragos sausage fried
poached egg 100 sauce garnish with
chives and we are done
[Music]
Panda Express orange chicken eggs
benedict very fancy let's bring back our
special guest Elise you challenged me I
did um Panda Express orange chicken and
I made something for you here I go
foreign
[Music]
eggs are my favorite food so seeing this
here yes is blowing my mind it looks so
beautiful life is just good right now
like I'm So Satisfied is this eggs
benedict I would love to try it yes
so how did you go about I wanted to make
everything with orange chicken that's
this mean
it is so delicious
ly the runny egg yolk oh the flavor is
so good okay so I taste the orange
chicken chickenininess it's like infused
into everything I dehydrated and I made
a kind of like dehydrated so many
different things and that's why it's
such an amazing culmination of just like
all your skills thank you I'm literally
gonna eat this whole thing do you think
this is a great hangover cure I do when
it comes to a hangover you want kind of
want to have something that's gonna like
take your mind off of the disaster that
your life currently is right so let's
try the origin Cheers Cheers
this is good you really great job thank
you so at least yes did I make Panda
Express orange chicken fancy you
absolutely did 100 yay all right so we
have one last thing to do three two one
make it fancy
yeah yeah
[Music]